[Music]
oh [ __ ]
it's a good one [ __ ]
oh yeah we got some whole Baba weed this
[ __ ] now this [ __ ] is grown at
the White House by black people they'll
[ __ ] around here
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
well well well what do we have here it's
my main man BAM
and uncle Joey coming together to greet
you a happy 4:40 getting stoned to the
gills
we got a container of something in the
black canister and we also have the Thin
Mint cookies [ __ ] all the shit's gone
already smoke the [ __ ]
this weed is tremendous in this canister
you understand if I even dry yet and
it's [ __ ] killing me
it's an early release look at it when
they take you to the back Michael that's
when you know it's all [ __ ] over you
understand me you're gonna hear people
yelling people getting stabbed I love it
this is what it's all about right here
everything else is background music that
[ __ ] you got and they told you it Callie
groans you got allowed to you got liked
it there's a drought in the stamp here
we go [ __ ] this is this [ __ ] that
kill [ __ ] lucifer now but if we burn
your fingers this [ __ ] and your
brother's that's a boy get down to the
ground
that's a boy thing event hit that
sandwich that's a beautiful thing
[Laughter]
look up you're not gonna spill out your
lungs what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
tremendous you don't think I'd bother
you right now mostly show up before
Maidan some brought under a [ __ ]
valley type reefer I bothered you
because what I'm smoking is this [ __ ]
they [ __ ] get up
this is something gonna carry me over
into the night this is it this is the
flu bug killer entering your system this
is called Obama from science and herbal
they've had it for years they started
this [ __ ] down Hollywood was 30 or
[ __ ] glam like six or seven years ago
I just happened to bump into the guy you
know how we do it we know people you
know people concept but when I do it
back yet
he got detained and [ __ ] French I'll
be back next week he contacted me today
via [ __ ] via via via everything come
let me know don't worry about nothing
he's got ash in the [ __ ] hole anyway
I'm getting spamming [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] hookah I'm showing up with a
high level [ __ ] THC [ __ ] hashish and
you wanna hang out with your [ __ ]
friends with a hat and smoke a hookah I
love this either smoking a hookah you're
smoking a long big there's really low
okay he's smoking a long skinny hummus
big it's [ __ ] long and you're like
your [ __ ] gooks get your life
together get it together that's right
[ __ ]
it's Thursday afternoon getting into
yourself what am I gonna deserve this
nothing here we are [ __ ] in Cali 4
o'clock 97 degree weather
one two what happened you know we don't
know how to count here on Sesame Street
West is the weed that [ __ ] saved Mary
Poppins
it's like a forest fire down there
checking on my whiskey you want to train
with Uncle Joe we gotta look deep it
ain't no time for this you know put a
filter on the joint don't bother me with
that [ __ ] we go freshen on the murky
waters on a daily
we've already hit the only rainbow you
need is in this [ __ ] pipe this is the
only rainbow right now Thursday July
28th the month is over half the summer's
gone whatever you [ __ ] done
what have you [ __ ] done anything 2016
is a [ __ ] memory you're sitting there
laughing at some fat [ __ ] duel with
his [ __ ] goop on smoking go get it
together turn this [ __ ] off now we're
gonna light it go stab somebody do
something like it might do some time
disease get straightened out and
something punchy but it's better than
sitting [ __ ] watching some fat [ __ ]
there's no [ __ ] Jewish occupation am
saying I wish I wish you could smell
this [ __ ] reefer right now look I had
an inside lease car and I could smell it
from outside the [ __ ] car that's how
fresh this is so whatever the [ __ ] you
wanna do I know you've been thinking
about things you know making hard
decisions with your life
it's time you got no job you're thinking
about gone ITT your mother's driving you
crazy your uncle's a [ __ ] loser give
it a shot
I see you got all day anyone know this
takes you to the next level see over
here come here we uncle Joey this is
this is when you got to attack those
cells right now so this is like rolling
when you're tired this is like rolling
it's Marcela madness there's no backing
it over your finger you know move around
there you go right there
I'm gonna bring their things which all
fresh
we're gonna make a [ __ ] soldier if
you wanna push smoke like a [ __ ]
soldier Joey Diaz I have a training
program blow clouds like Snoop Dogg
within two weeks or your money back
two weeks it's a two-week training
course I missed it I mix it with doctor
police's training course I get you
blowing [ __ ] clouds people uninvite
you from parties understand
[Music]
satisfaction guaranteed or your money
back it's a rigorous training program
sleep apnea bastard running backwards
yeah we don't fall around fine with a
bar running with a bomb
jumping jacks this is my [ __ ] cross
cross training with a bum I got the
whole [ __ ] work I'd say plus there's
no wave limitations 600-800
we want somebody weighs a thousand
pounds we want to put the final hatchet
in your [ __ ] heart right in one of
these bong hits we'll send you the
[ __ ] Jupiter and back yet the
stamping but anyway it was nice hanging
out with you guys
always a pleasure you know I love you
mother [ __ ] wall my heart I come on
in with the afternoon of a cup of my
[ __ ] family who supports us you love
us we love you [ __ ] - that's the only
reason you think we would do leave you
ready for another one
and Lee's ready for a [ __ ] number one
what have you done with your life you
understand me you're their [ __ ]
judging us but you don't know what the
first practical act means it's our other
degrees it's on it's like the [ __ ]
Philippines out here we're smoking
[ __ ] luggage you understand me why
cuz we don't give a Frenchman's for MA
if you're trying to take it to the next
level you understand even the satellite
lights are turning down because they
don't want us to get the message
I don't know my canister bottle the
[ __ ] plague still hot you are
experiencing
slowly slowly smother you got there you
go that's what's up
[Music]
people
let's exercise
cuz I love you [ __ ] you see any
[ __ ] stories here you said it
celebrity if you see any [ __ ] this is
just two fat [ __ ] have a good time
though happy to death right get me to
him to this [ __ ] gun
have a great [ __ ] bag come on IDI
South 1015
the Icehouse Baron Claude is shown I'm
doing at 9:30 Saturday night 20 minutes
you know I'm just trying to work things
out for the special next Thursday a flap
is next time they have [ __ ] not the
casino and Cherokee in the Cherokee
Casino and Oklahoma what do you what do
you want from me I just did [ __ ] them
both you wouldn't even know what the
[ __ ] your name was if you were smoking
this [ __ ] and they were going to do this
last one
I love you guys have a great night wait
the cops are coming
somebody call the cops I'm telling you
that was the funniest [ __ ] them last
thing it's not like I thought I'm 16
kick them on the [ __ ] spot all right
I love you guys have a great [ __ ]
night the church 400 is uploaded my
little brothers are savage go out there
get this guy I can just kind of [ __ ]
around you understand you don't [ __ ]
around
soldiers were creating here even if it's
just three of us that's all we need to
start this [ __ ] revolution it's over
stay black I love you tomorrow